I actually had one to begin by going back to Freud and hitting a couple of loose
ends.
There was a point in my lecture on Wednesday what I skipped over some parts.
I said,
we don't have time for this.
And I just whipped passed it and I couldn't sleep that we over the weekend been
tormented.
Um,
I shouldn't have skipped that.
And,
and I want to break,
let me tell you why I skipped it.
The discussion I skipped was a discussion of why we would have an unconscious at
all.
So it was talking about the scientifically respectable ideas of Freud.
And I want to talk about some new ideas about why there could be an unconscious.
Now,
the reason why I skipped it is I'm not sure this is the best way to look at the
question as we will learn throughout the course.
By far the vast majority of what our brains do,
the vast majority of what our minds do is unconscious and we're unaware of it.
So the right question to ask may not be why are some things unconscious,
but rather at,
why is this tiny subset of mental life,
why is this conscious?
On the other hand,
these claims about the utility of unconsciousness,
I think are provocative and interesting.
So I just wanted to quickly share them with you.
Um,
so the question is,
from an evolutionary standpoint,
why would an unconscious evolve and an answer that some psychologists and
biologists have given his deception.
So most animals do.
Some deception and deception defined broadly is simply act or be in some way
that fools others into believing or thinking or responding to something that's
false.
Um,
there's physical examples of deception when threatened chimpanzees,
they're here,
stands up on end and that makes them look bigger to fool others to think,
you know,
more dangerous than they are.
Um,
there's an angler fish at the bottom of the ocean that has a rod sticking up
from the top of its head with ular to capture other fish,
to fool them and thinking that this is something edible and then to themselves
be devoured.
But humans,
primates in general,
but particularly humans,
um,
are masters at deception.
We use our minds and our behaviors and our actions continually to try to trick
people into believing what's not true.
We try to trick people,
for instance,
I'm into believing that were tougher,
smarter,
sexier,
more reliable,
more trustworthy,
and so on.
Then we really are,
and a large part of social psychology concerns the way in which we present
ourselves to other people so as to make the maximum we positive impression even
when that impression isn't true.
Um,
at the same time though,
we've also evolve very good lie detection mechanisms.
So not only is their evolutionary pressure for me to lie to you,
for me to persuade you,
for instance,
that if we're going to have a calm,
if you're threatening me,
don't threaten me.
I am not the sort of man you could screw around with.
But there is evolutionary pressure for you to look and say,
no,
you are an accord,
a man you get screw around with.
I could tell.
So how do you,
how do you become a good liar?
And here's where the unconscious comes in the iPod is,
is,
is the best lies are lies we tell ourselves you're a better liar more generally
if you believe the lie that you're telling.
Um,
this could be illustrated with a story by a about Alfred Hitchcock.
The story goes,
he hated working with truck,
with child actors,
but he often had to,
and the story goes,
he was dealing with a child actor who simply could not cry.
And finally frustrated.
Hitchcock wintered actor leaned over,
whispered in his ear,
your parents have left you and they're never coming back.
The kid burst into tears.
Hitchcock said,
Roland and filling the kid
and the kid,
if you were to see him today,
that's boy,
he's really,
he really looks as if he's sad because he was,
um,
if I had a competition of where I give $100,000 to the person who looks the most
as if they are in pain,
it is a very good tactic to take a pen and jam it into your groin because you
will look extremely persuasively as if you are in pain.
If I want to persuade you that I love you would never leave you.
You can trust me with everything.
It may be a superb tactic for me to believe it.
And so this accounted evolution of the unconscious,
um,
is that certain motivations and goals,
particularly sinister ones,
are better made to be unconscious because of a person doesn't know they have
them,
they will not give them away.
And this is something I think we should return to later on when we talk about
social interaction and social relationships.
Um,
one other thing on Freud as just a story of the false suffocation of Freud.
I was taking my younger child home from a play date on Sunday and he asked me
out of the blue,
why can't you marry your mother or your father?
Now that's actually a difficult question to ask answer for a child.
But I tried my best to give them an answer and then I said,
um,
then I thought back on the Freud lecture.
And so I asked him if you could marry anybody you want,
who would it be imagining?
He make explicit the oedipal complex and main name his mother.
Um,
instead he paused for a moment and said I would marry a donkey
and a big bag of peanuts.
Both,
both his parents are psychologists and he hates these questions and tiny you
just screws around with us.
Okay.
Last class
I started with Freud and I want to turn to Skinner and the story of Skinner and
science is somewhat different from the story of Freud.
Freud developed and champion the theory of psycho analysis by himself.
It is as close as you could find in science to a solitary invention.
Um,
obviously he drew upon all sorts of sources and predecessors,
but psycho analysis identified as Freud's creation.
Behaviorism is different.
Behaviorism is a school of thought that was there long before Skinner championed
by a psychologist like a John Watson for instance.
Skinner came a bit late into this,
but the reason why we've heard of Skinner and why skin are so well known is he
packaged these notions he expanded upon and we publicized them.
He developed them scientifically and presented in both to the scientific
community and to the popular community.
And sociologically in the 1960s,
1970s,
United States behaviorism was incredibly well known.
So it was Skinner.
He was,
uh,
he was a sort of person you would see on talk shows.
His books were bestsellers.
I'm now at the core of behaviorism are three extremely radical and interesting
views.
The first is a strong emphasis on learning.
The strong view of behaviorism is everything.
You know,
everything you are is a result of experience.
There's no real human nature.
Rather people are infinitely malleable.
Um,
there's a wonderful quote from John Watson and in this quote,
John Watson is a paraphrasing,
a famous boasts by the Jesuits.
The Jesuits used to claim,
give me a child until the age of seven and I'll show you the man that they would
take a child and turn them into anything they wanted.
And Watson expanded on this post,
give me a dozen healthy infants well formed and my own specified world to bring
them up and,
and I'll guarantee to take anyone at random and train them to become any type of
specialist.
I might select doctor,
lawyer,
artists,
merchant chief,
and yes,
even beggar man thief.
Regardless of his talents,
pensions,
tendencies,
abilities,
vocations,
and race of his ancestors.
Now you could imagine,
you could see in this a tremendous appeal to this view.
Um,
because Watson,
it's an extremely egalitarian view in a sense.
If there's no human nature,
then there's no sense in which one group of humans,
um,
by dent of their race or their sex could be better than another group.
And Watson was explicit.
None of those facts about people will ever make any difference.
What matters to what you are is what you learn and how you're treated.
And so wants and claim he could create anybody in any way simply by treating
them in a certain fashion.
MMM.
A second aspect of behaviorism was anti mentalism.
And what I mean by this is the behaviors were obsessed with the idea of doing
science and they felt largely in reaction to Freud that claims of an internal
mental states like desires,
wishes,
goals,
emotions,
and so on.
Our unscientific,
these invisible,
vague things can never form the basis of a serious science.
And so to behaviors manifesto would then be to develop a science will anything
that's unobservable and instead use notions like stimulus and response and
reinforcement and punishment and environment that refer to real world and
tangible events.
Finally,
behavior is believed.
There were no interesting differences across species.
I behaviors might admit that a human can do things that a rat or pigeon
couldn't,
but behavior is might just say,
look,
there was or just general associate of powers that differ.
Or they may even deny it.
They might say humans and rats aren't different at all.
It's just humans tend to live in a richer environment than rats.
Um,
from that standpoint,
from that theoretical standpoint comes to methodological approach,
which is if they're all the same,
then you can study human learning by studying nonhuman animals.
And that's a lot of what they did.
Okay.
I'm going to frame my introduction,
my discussion of behaviors and in terms of the three main learning principles
that they argued can explain all of human,
um,
mental life,
all of human behavior.
And then I want to turn to objections to behaviorism.
But these three principles are powerful and very interesting.
Yeah.
The first is habituation.
This is the very simplest form of learning.
And what this is,
is,
uh,
is re described as a decline in a tendency to respond to stimuli that are
familiar due to repeated exposure.
Hey,
okay,
hey,
the sudden noise startles.
But,
but as it,
as you hear it,
the second time it startles less third time.
It's just me being goofy.
It's just,
it's you get used to things now.
And this,
of course,
it's common enough in everyday life we get used to the ticking of a clock or the
noise of traffic.
Um,
but it's actually a very important form of learning
because
imagine life without it.
Imagine life where,
where you never got used to anything where,
you know,
something,
somebody steps forward and waves her hand go,
huh.
And then they were drunk girl.
And You keep and you know,
and,
and there's,
there's a loud ticking of a clock and he's like,
whoa.
And you know,
that's not the way animals or humans work.
You get used to things and it's actually critically important to get used to
things.
Um,
because it's a useful adaptive mechanism to keep track on new events and
objects.
It's important to notice something when it's no because then you have to decide
whether it's going to harm you,
how to deal with it,
to attend to it,
but you can't keep on noticing it.
And in fact you should stop noticing it after it's been in an environment for
long enough.
So this counts as learning because it happens through experience.
It's a way to learn through experience,
to change it,
your way of thinking through experience.
And also it's useful,
um,
because harmful stimuli are noticed.
But when something has shown itself to be part of the environment,
you don't notice it anymore.
Um,
the existence of habituation is important for many reasons.
One thing that's important for is clever.
Developmental psychologists have used habituation as a way to study,
um,
people,
creatures who can talk like nonhuman animals and young babies.
And when I talk on Wednesday,
but developmental psychology,
I'll show different ways in which psychologists have used habituation to study
the minds of young babies.
The second sort of learning is known as classical conditioning.
And what this is
in a very general sense is the learning of an association between one stimulus
and another stimulus where stimulus is a technical term,
meaning events in an environment like a certain smell or sound or site.
Um,
it was thought up by a Pavlov.
This is Pavlov's famous dog and this is an example of scientific serendipity.
Pavlov,
when he started this research had no interest at all in learning.
He was interested in saliva and to get saliva he had to have dogs and he had to
attach something to dog so that their saliva would pour it out.
So he could study saliva,
no idea why he wanted to study alive.
Um,
but he then discovered something.
What he would do is he put food powder in the dog's mouth,
degenerate saliva.
But Pavlov observed that when somebody entered the room who typically gave him
the food powder,
the dog to food pattern,
saliva would start to come out.
And later on,
if you right before or right during,
you give the dog some food,
you,
you ping a bell,
the bell will cost the saliva to come forth.
Um,
and in fact,
this is the apparatus that he used for his research.
He developed a theory plastic conditioning by making a distinction between two
sorts of conditioning to sorts of stimulus response relationships.
One is unconditioned and I'm condition is when an unconditioned stimulus gives
rise to an unconditioned response.
And this is what you start off with.
So if somebody pokes you with a stick and you say,
ouch,
because it hurts the poking and the out is an unconditioned stimulus causing an
unconditioned response,
you didn't have to learn that when Pavlov put food powder in a dog's mouth and
saliva was generated,
that's an unconditioned stimulus giving rise and then condition response.
But what happens through learning is that another association develops that
between the condition stimulus and the conditioned response.
So when Pavlov,
for instance,
um,
well when Pav law for instance,
started before conditioning,
there was simply an unconditioned stimulus,
the food and a mouth and an unconditioned response.
Saliva.
The bell was nothing.
Bell was a neutral stimulus.
But over and over again,
if you put the bell and the food together,
okay,
pretty soon the bell will generate saliva.
And now the bell,
when you start off with the unconditioned stimulus,
unconditioned response,
when the condition stimulus,
an unconditioned stimulus are brought together over and over and over again,
pretty soon the condition stimulus gives rise to the response.
And now it's known as the condition stimulus giving rise to the condition
response.
This is discussed in detail in textbook,
but it also,
I'm going to give it,
don't,
don't panic if you don't get quiet.
Now I'm going to you further and further examples.
Um,
so the idea here is repeated pairings of the unconditioned stimulus and the
conditioned stimulus,
um,
will give rise to the response.
And there's a difference between reinforced trials and unreinforced trials.
Uh,
reinforce trial is when the conditioned stimulus,
an unconditioned stimulus go together.
Your tee it up,
put it in a crude way.
You're teaching the dog that the bell goes with the food.
An unreinforced trial is when,
um,
you get the food without the bell.
You're not teaching the dog this.
And in fact,
once you teach an animal something,
if you stopped doing the teaching,
the response goes away.
And this is known as extinction.
So here's a graph.
Um,
if you,
you get it,
they really count the number of cubic centimeters a saliva.
The dog is trained so that when the bell comes on,
actually your misframed it,
I'll try again.
When the bell comes,
um,
connected with food,
there's a lot of saliva and unreinforced responses when the bill goes on,
but there is no food.
So it's like,
imagine you're,
you're,
you're the dog so you get food in the mouth,
bell food,
Bill food,
and now bell.
But next you get bell Bell Bell,
you give it up,
you stop.
This isn't working.
You stop responding to the bell.
A weird thing which is discussing a textbook is if you wait a while and then you
try it again,
if the bell,
after a couple of hours,
the saliva comes back.
This is known as spontaneous recovery.
So this all seems very technical phenomena related to animals and the like.
Um,
but it's easy to see how a generalizes and how it extends.
One interesting notion is that a stimulus,
generalization and stimulus generalization,
um,
is the topic of one of your articles in the Norden reader.
The one by Watson,
John Watson,
the famous behaviors who reported a bizarre experiment with a baby known as
little Albert.
Um,
and here's the idea.
A little Albert originally like rats.
If I'm going to show you a movie of Little Albert Originally Liking Rhett's,
see he's okay.
No problem.
Now Watson did something interesting
as little Albert was playing with the Rad.
Oh,
I like rats.
Watson wind behind the baby.
This is in the,
it's in the chapter.
And Bang,
the metal bar right there,
baby scream started to sob.
Okay,
what's the unconditioned stimulus?
Somebody,
the loud noise.
The bar to bang.
What's the unconditioned response?
Crying,
sadness,
misery.
Um,
and as a result of this little Albert grew afraid of the rat.
So there,
what would be the condition?
Stimulus.
The rat.
What would be the condition response?
Fear.
Excellent.
Moreover,
this,
this fear extended to other things.
So this is,
this is a very weird and unpersuasive clip,
but the idea is the clip is to make the point that the fear will extend to a
rabbit,
a white rabbit.
So the first part,
we'll Albert's fine with the white rabbit.
The second part is after he's been conditioned and he's kind of freaked out with
the right rabbit.
The problem is in the second part that we're throwing the rabbit at them,
but
now he's,
okay,
Micah,
this is going,
this is one of a long list of experiments that we can't do anymore.
Um,
so
classical conditioning is more than a laboratory phenomenon.
Um,
the findings of classical conditioning have been extended and replicated in all
sorts of animals,
including crabs,
fish,
cockroaches and so on.
And it's been argued to be an extension of
argued to underlie certain interesting aspects of human responses.
So I have some examples here.
One example is fear.
So the Little Albert idea,
um,
the little Albert experiment provides an illustration for how phobias could
emerge.
Some proportion of people in this room have phobias.
Imagine you're afraid of dogs.
Well,
a possible story for the,
for why he became afraid of dogs,
um,
is that one day a dog came up and he was a neutral stimulus,
no problem.
And all of a sudden he beat you.
Now the pain of a bite being bit and then the pain and fear of that is an
unconditioned stimulus.
Unconditioned response.
You're just born with that out.
But the presence of the dog,
there is a condition stimulus.
And so you grew to be afraid of dogs.
If you believe this.
This also forms the basis for ways,
for theory of how you could make phobias go away.
How do you make conditioned stimulus?
Conditioned response links go away.
Well what you do is you extinguish no extinguish them when you show the thing
that would cause you to have the fear with l the unconditioned stimulus.
Here's a,
an illustration.
Um,
it's a joke site.
He's a simultaneous,
the confronting the fear of heights,
snakes and the dark cause he's trapped in that thing.
And the logic is the logic.
The logic is not that he stuck in there.
Those are all the t conditioned stimulus,
but nothing bad happens.
So his fear goes away.
The problem with this is while stuck in there,
he has a screaming horrific panic attack and then it makes us fear much worse.
So what they do now though,
and we'll talk about this much later in the course when we talk about clinical
psychology,
but one cure for phobias does draw upon in a more intelligent way to behaviorist
literature.
So the claim I've got a phobia is that there's a bad association between say dog
and fear or between airplanes or snakes and some bad response.
So what they do is what's called systematic desensitization,
which is they expose you to what causes you the fear,
but they relax you at the same time.
So you replace the averse of classical conditioning fear with something more
positive.
Um,
traditionally they used to teach people relaxation exercises,
but that proves too difficult.
So nowadays they just pump you full of some drug.
You you're really happy and so you really stoned out of your head.
You're,
you're there if the dog,
cause I,
this isn't so bad,
it's more complicated in that,
but the notion is you can use these associated tools perhaps to,
um,
to deal with questions about fear,
phobias and how they go away.
Um,
hunger.
We'll spend some time in this course discussing why we eat and when we eat.
And one answer to why we and when we is that there's cues in the environment
that are associated with eating and these cues generate,
um,
hunger.
For those of you who,
um,
who are trying to quit smoking,
you'll notice that there's time or quit drinking.
There's times of the day or certain activities that really make you want to
smoke are really make you want a drink.
And from a behavioral point of view,
this is because of the associated history of these things.
Um,
more speculative lay,
um,
classical conditioning has been argued to,
to be implicated in a formation of sexual desire including fetishes.
So a behavior,
a story about fetishes for instance is,
um,
it's straight forward classical conditioning.
Just as your lover's caress brings you to orgasm,
your eyes happen to fall upon the shoe
through the simple tools of plasma conditioning,
then the issue becomes a condition stimulus are giving rise to the conditioned
response of sexual pleasure.
Um,
this almost certainly is not the right story,
but again,
just as an phobia,
some ideas of classic conditioning May,
um,
may play some role in determining what we like and what we don't like sexually.
And in fact,
one treatment for pedophiles and rapists involved controlled fantasies during
masturbation to shift the association from domination and violence,
for instance,
um,
to develop a more positive associations with sexual pleasure.
So the strong class conditioning stories about fetishes and fears sounds silly
and extreme and they probably are,
but at the same time,
classic conditioning can be used at least to shape the focus of our desires and
our interest.
Um,
final thought exercise.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
So what do we think about classic conditioning?
We talked about what habituation is for,
what's classical conditioning for?
Well,
a traditional view is it's not for anything.
It's just association.
So what happens is the ucs and to see us,
the bell and the food go together because they happen at the same time.
And so classical conditioning should be the strongest when these tourists are
simultaneous.
And the response to one is the same as the response to the other.
This is actually no longer the mainstream view.
The mainstream view is now a little bit more interesting.
It's that what happens in class of conditioning is preparation.
What happens is
you become sensitive to a queue that an event is about to happen and that allows
you to prepare for the event.
Um,
this make certain predictions.
It predicts that the best timing is when the condition stimulus,
which is the signal comes before the unconditioned stimulus,
which is what you have to prepare for.
And it says the condition response may be different from the unconditioned
response.
So move away from food.
Imagine a child who is being beaten by his father and when his father raises his
hand,
he flinches last classical conditioning.
What happened in that cases,
he has learned that the raising of the hand is a signal that he is about to be
hit.
And so he responds to that signal.
His flinch is not the same response that one would give if one's hit.
If you're hit,
you don't flinch.
If you hit,
you might feel pain or bounce back or something.
Flinching is preparation for being hit.
And in general the idea that what goes on in class of conditioning is that the
response is sort of a preparation.
The condition response is a preparation for the unconditioned stimulus.
Um,
glass conditioning shows up all over the place as a final exercise and had to
think about it.
Has Anybody here seen the movie clockwork orange
audio?
Um,
it's kind of a shocking movie and,
and unpleasant and very violent,
but at its core,
one of the main themes is a right out of intro psych.
It's classical conditioning.
So our main character who's a violent murder and rapists is brought in by some
psychologists for some therapy and the therapy gets his class with conditioning
in particular,
what happens is he has given a drug that makes him violently ill,
extremely nauseous,
and then his eyes are prompt,
open and he's shown scenes of violence as a result of this sort of conditioning.
He then when he experienced his real world violence,
he responds with nausea and shock.
Basically training him to to get away from class from,
from these acts of violence.
In this example,
take a moment.
Don't say it out loud.
Just take a more,
what's the unconditioned stimulus?
Okay.
Anybody?
What's the unconditioned stimulus?
Somebody just say it.
Good.
The drug.
What's the unconditioned response?
Nausea.
What's the condition?
Stimulus.
Violence.
What's the condition response?
Perfect.
The third and final type of learning is known as opera and conditioning or
instrumental conditioning,
and this is the thing.
This is the theory championed and developed most extensively by Skinner.
What this is is learning the relationships between what you do and how
successful or unsuccessful they are.
Learning what works and what doesn't.
It's important.
This is very different from classical conditioning and one way to see how this
is different is for classical conditioning.
You don't do anything.
You could literally be strapped down and be immobile.
Entities.
Connections are what you appreciate and you make connections in your mind.
Instrumental conditioning is voluntary.
You choose to do things and by dint of your choices,
some choices become more learn than others.
So the idea itself was developed in a nicest form,
um,
by Thorndyke who explored how animals learn.
Remember,
behaviorists work entirely comfortable studying animals and drawing
extrapolations to other animals and to humans.
So he would put a cat in a puzzle box.
And the trick to a puzzle box is there's a simple way to get out,
but you have to kind of pull on something.
So special lever to make it pop open.
And Thorndyke noted that cats do not solve this problem through insight.
They don't get to sit in the box for a while and mull it over
and then figure out how to do it.
Instead.
What they do is they bounce all around doing different things and gradually get
better and better at it.
So what they do is,
um,
the first rally might scratch at the bars,
portrait portraits,
ceiling ticketed for Howell,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And one or their behaviors is pressing the lever.
The lever gets to better to box.
But after more and more trials,
they stopped scratching.
At the bar is pushing it to ceiling and so on.
They just pressed the lever.
And if you graph it,
they gradually get better and better.
They throw it,
all of these behaviors randomly,
some of them get reinforced.
And those are the ones that survive and others don't get reinforced.
And those are the ones that go extinct.
And it might occur to some of you that this seems to be an analogy with a
Darwinian theory of natural selection where there's a random assortment of,
of,
um,
random mutations and sexual selections give rise to a host of organisms,
some which survive and are fit and others which aren't.
And in fact,
Skinner,
um,
explicitly made the analogy from the natural selection of species to the natural
selection of behavior.
So this could be summarized as the law of effect,
which is a tendency to perform an actions increased if rewarded.
We can,
if it's not.
And Skinner extended this,
um,
more generally.
So the illustrate,
um,
Skinnerian theory and operant conditioning.
I'll give an example of,
of training a pig.
So here's the idea.
You,
you need to train a pig and you need to do so through opera and conditioning.
So one of the you want to do is the pig is going to do some things you like and
some things you don't like.
And so what you want to do,
basically drawing upon the law of effect is reinforced a pig for doing good
things.
So what did you want to pick to walk forward?
So you reinforce the pig for walking forward and you punish the pig for walking
backward.
And if you do that over the fullness of time,
your reinforcement and punishment will give rise to a pig who walks forward.
There's two,
one technical distinction that people love to put on an intro psych exams is
that the different in positive reinforcement and negative reinforcement
reinforcement is something that makes the behavior increase.
Negative reinforcement is very different from punishment,
negative reinforcement.
It's just a type of reward.
The differences and positive reinforcement.
You do something in negative reinforcement,
you take away something a versa.
So imagine the pig has a heavy color and to reward the pig for walking forward,
you might remove the heavy color.
So these are the basic techniques to train an animal.
But it's kind of silly because the boilers,
you want your pigs,
the dance,
um,
you don't just want you to pick to walk forward,
you want your pig to dance.
Well,
you can't adopt the policy of I'm going to wait for this pig to dance and when
it does and went to reinforce it because it would take you a very long time.
Um,
similarly,
if you're dealing with,
um,
with,
with immature humans and you want your child to get you a beer,
you can't just sit,
wait for the kid to give you a beer,
like grab a bottle and say excellent,
good hugs.
You gotta work your way to it and act of working your way to it is known as
shaping.
So here is how to get a pig to dance.
You wait for the pig to do something that's halfway close to dancing,
like stumbling and you reward it.
Then it does something else that's even closer to the dancing.
And you reward it and you keep rewarding it as it gets closer to closer.
Here's how to get your child to bring you some beer.
You say,
Johnny,
could you go to the kitchen and get me some beer?
And he walks to the kitchen and then he forgets why he's there and you went up
there.
You're such a good kid.
Congratulations.
Hugs.
And then,
and then you get them to,
and finally you get them to also open up the refrigerator and get the beer open
liver get.
And in that way you can train preachers to do complicated things.
Um,
Skinner had many examples of this Skinner developed in World War Two,
a pigeon guided missile.
It was never actually used,
but it was a great idea.
And people in fact that the history of the military in the United States and
other countries includes a lot of attempts to get animals like pigeons are
dolphins to do interesting and deadly things through various training.
Um,
more recreational.
Skinner was fond of teaching animals to play ping pong.
And again,
you don't teach an animal play ping pong by waiting for her to play ping pong
and then rewarding it.
Rather you,
you reward approximations to it.
Now in basically they're our primary reinforcers.
There are some things pigs naturally like,
um,
food for instance.
There are some things pigs actually automatically don't like,
like being hit or but in the real world when dealing with humans.
But even when dealing with animals,
we don't actually always use primary reinforcers are negative reinforcement.
What you,
we often use are things like for my dog saying good dog.
Now saying good dog is not something that dog has been built pre wired to find
pleasurable.
But what happens is you can do a two step process.
You can make good dog positive through classical conditioning.
You give the dog a treat and say good dog.
Now the phrase good dog will carry the rewarding quality and you could use that
rewarding quality in order to train it.
And through this way,
behaviors have developed token economies where they get nonhuman animals to do
interesting things for seemingly arbitrary rewards like poker chips.
Um,
and in this way you can increase the utility and ease of training.
finally
in the examples we're giving,
whenever the pig does something you like,
you reinforce it.
But that's not how real life works.
Real life for both humans and animals involved.
Cases where the reinforcement doesn't happen all the time but actually happens
according to different schedules.
And so there is a distinction between fixed schedules versus ratios,
variable schedules and ratio versus interval.
And this is something you would print out to look at.
I don't need to go over in detail.
The difference between um,
ratio is a reward every certain number of times somebody does something.
So if every 10th time your dog brought you to newspaper,
you gave it huddles and treats,
that's ratio and interval is over a period of time.
So if your dog gives you,
um,
if your dog,
I dunno,
dances for an hour straight,
that would be an interval saying and
fixed versus variable speaks to whether you give a reward on a fixed schedule
like every fifth time or variable,
sometimes under third time,
sometimes on the seventh time and so on.
And these are there examples here and had no need to go over them.
It's easy enough to think of examples,
um,
in real life.
So for example,
um,
a slot machine is variable ratio.
It goes off after it's been hit a certain number of times.
It doesn't matter how long it takes you for to do it,
it's a number of times you pull it down,
but it's variable because it doesn't always go off and the thousands of time you
don't know it's unpredictable.
The slot machine is a good example of a phenomena known as the partial
reinforcement effect.
And this is kind of neat.
It makes it makes sense when you hear it,
but it's a sort of finding that's been validated over and over again with
animals and nonhumans.
Here's the idea.
Suppose you want to train somebody to do something and you want a training such
that they'll keep on doing it even if you're not training them anymore,
which is typically what you want
if you want that.
The trick is don't reinforce it all the time.
Behaviors last longer.
If they're reinforced intermittently,
and this is known as the partial reinforcement effect.
Thinking of this psychologically as it's as if,
if whenever you put something in a slot machine,
it gave you money,
then all of a sudden it stopped.
You keep on doing it a few times,
but then he'd say,
fine,
it doesn't work.
But what if it gave you money one out of every hundred times?
Now you keep on trying.
And because the reinforcement is intermittent,
you don't expect it as much.
And so your behavior will persist across often a huge amount of time.
I mean,
here's a good example.
What's the very worst thing to do when your kid cries to go into bed with you?
Okay.
And you don't want him to go into bed with you.
Well,
one,
the worst thing to do is for any asked you for any form of discipline with a kid
is to say no.
Absolutely not.
No,
no,
no.
Okay.
And then later on the kid's going to say,
I want to do it again.
And
you say,
no.
I think he's,
uh,
the kid keeps asking because you could put it the way,
I'll put it in a psychological way,
not the way to behaviors.
We've put it,
the kid knows,
oh,
he's not going to get it right away.
He's gonna keep on asking.
And so typically what you're doing in the advertently in those situations is
you're exploiting the partial reinforcement effect.
If I want my kid to do something,
I should say yes one out of every 10 times.
Unfortunately that's the evolution of nagging because you nag,
Nag,
Nag person says fine.
Okay.
And that reinforces it.
Um,
if Skinner kept the focus on rats and pigeons and dogs,
um,
he would not have the impact that he did,
but he argued that you could extend all of these notions to humans and the human
behavior.
So for example,
he argued that the prison system needs to be reformed because instead of
focusing on notions of justice and retribution,
um,
well we should do is focus instead on questions of reinforcing good behaviors
and punishing bad ones.
He argued for the notions of awkward and conditioning to be extended to everyday
life.
And argue that people's lives would became fuller and more satisfying if they
were controlled in a properly behaviors.
Wait,
any questions about behaviorism?
What are your questions about behaviorism?
Wow.
Yes.
Good question.
The discussion was over using things like poker chips for reinforcement,
and the point is exactly right.
Since the connection of the poker chips is established through classical
conditioning,
sooner or later by that logic,
the poker chips would lose their power to serve as reinforce it.
You'd have to sort of start it up again.
Retrain.
Okay.
Again,
if you have a dog and you say,
good dog to reward the dog by your logic,
which is right,
at some point you might as well give the dog a treat.
A lot of good dog,
otherwise good dog is not gonna cut it anymore.
Yes.
Brilliant.
Um,
as far as I know,
um,
Skinner and Skinnerian psychologist were never directly involved in the creation
of prisons.
On the other hand,
the psychological theory,
behaviorism has had a huge impact and I think a lot of people's ways of thinking
about criminal justice and criminal law has been shaped by behavior principles.
So,
for instance,
institutions like mental institutions and some prisons have installed token
economies where there's rewards for good behavior,
often poker chips of a sword,
and then you could cash them in for other things.
And to some extent these had been shaped by an adherence to behaviors.
Principles.
Okay.
Um,
so here are the three general positions of behaviorism,
um,
that there is no innate knowledge.
All you need is learning that you could explain human psychology without mental
notions like desires and goals.
And at these mechanisms apply across all domains and across all species.
I think it's fair to say that right now,
just about everybody agrees all of these three claims are mistaken.
Okay.
First,
we know that it's not true,
that everything is learned.
There's considerable evidence,
different forms of innate knowledge and innate desires.
And we'll look,
look when,
we'll talk about it in detail.
When we look at case studies like language learning,
uh,
the development of sexual preference,
the developing understanding of material objects,
there's a lot of debate over how much is innate and what the character of the
builtin mental systems are.
But there's nobody who delts nowadays that I considerable amount for humans and
Fernando other animals is built in.
Is it true that talking about mental state does unscientific?
Um,
nobody believes this anymore,
either.
A science,
particularly more advanced sciences like physics or chemistry are all a belt
unobservable is they're all about things you can't see.
Um,
and it makes sense to explain complex and intelligent behavior in terms of
internal mechanisms and internal representations.
Once again,
the computer revolution has served as an illustrative case study.
Um,
if you have a computer that plays chess and you want to explain how the computer
plays chess,
it's impossible to do so without talking about the programs and mechanisms
inside the computer.
Is it true that animals need reinforcement and punishment to learn?
Now,
and there's several demonstrations at the time of Skinner suggesting that they
don't.
This is from a classic study by Toleman where rats were taught to,
um,
run a maze.
And what they found was the rats did fine.
They learn to run a maze faster and faster when they're regularly rewarded.
But they also learned to run a maze faster and faster if they're not rewarded at
all.
So to reward helps,
but the reward is in no sense,
um,
necessary.
And here's a more sophisticated illustration of the same point
and this is a sort of finding an old finding from before most of you were born.
Um,
that was a huge embarrassment for the Skinnerian theory as I suggest that rats
in fact hadn't mental maps,
um,
an internal mechanism that he used to understand the world entirely contrary to
the behaviorist idea,
everything can be explained in terms of reinforcement and punishment.
Um,
finally,
is it true that there's no animal specific constraints for learning?
And again,
the answer seems to be no.
Um,
animals for instance,
have natural responses so you could train a pigeon to peck for food.
But that's because packing for food is a very natural response,
is very difficult to train it,
to peck,
to escape a situation.
You can train it to flap its wings to escape a situation,
but it's very difficult to get it to flap.
It's wings for food.
And the idea is they have sort of natural responses that these learning
situations might exploit and my channel,
but essentially they do have certain natural ways of acting towards the world.
Um,
we know that not all stimuli and responses are created equal.
So the Grade Hex book has a very nice discussion of the Garcia effect and the
Garcia effect goes like this.
Okay.
Does anybody here have any food aversions?
I don't mean foods you don't like.
I mean foods that,
that really make you sick.
Okay.
Often food aversions and humans and other animals can be formed through it.
A form of association.
What happens is suppose you have the flu and you get very nauseous and then at
the same point you eat some Sashimi for the first time.
The connection between being nauseous and eating a new food is very potent.
And even if you know intellectually full well that the Sashimi isn't why you
became nauseous,
still you'll develop an aversion to this new food.
When I was younger,
uh,
when I was a teenager,
I dranked as a Greek Lik cure,
uh,
Ouzo with,
with beer.
I didn't really have a flu at the time,
but I became violently ill and as a result I cannot abide the smell of that
Greek word cure.
Now thank God it didn't develop an aversion to beer but but
but small miracles but um,
but the smell is the smell is very distinctive and for me was new to me.
And so through the Garcia effect I developed a strong aversion was interesting
though is the version is special.
So if you take an animal and you give it a new food and then you give it a drug
to make it nauseous,
it will avoid that food.
But if you take an animal and you give it a new food and then you shock it very
painfully,
it won't avoid a new food.
And the idea is that a connection when what something tastes and getting sick,
it is natural.
We are hardwired to say,
look,
if I'm needed a new food and I'm going to get nauseous,
I'm going to avoid that food.
The Garcia fact is that this is special to taste.
The nausea,
it doesn't extend more generally.
Finally,
I talked about phobias and now return to phobias later on in this course,
but the claim that people have formed their phobias through classical
conditioning is almost always wrong.
Instead,
it turns out that there are certain phobias that were specially evolve to have.
So both humans and chimpanzees for instance,
are particularly prone to develop fears of snakes.
And when we talk about the emotions later on in the course,
we'll talk about this in more detail,
but what seems likely is the sort of phobias you're likely to have does not have
much to do with your personal history,
but rather it has a lot to do with your evolutionary history.
Finally,
the other reading you're going to do for this part section of the course is
Chomsky's classic article.
His review of verbal behavior,
um,
Chomsky is one of the most prominent intellectuals alive.
He's still a professor at Mit,
still publishes on language and thought among other matters.
Um,
and the excerpt you're going to read is from his review of verbal behavior.
And this is one of the most influential intellectual documents ever written in
psychology because it took the entire discipline of behaviorism and more than
everything else,
more than any other event could be said to have destroyed it or ended it as a
dominant intellectual endeavor.
And Chomsky,
his argument is complicated and interesting,
but the main sort of argument he had to make is go,
it goes like this when it comes to humans,
the notions of reward and punishment and so on that Skinner tried to extend the
humans are so vague,
it's not science anymore.
And remember the discussion we had with regard to Freud with Skinner Chomsky is
raising here is the concern of an falsifiability.
So here's a sort of example.
He would discuss Skinner in his book.
Verbal behavior talks about the question of why do we do things like talk to
ourselves.
Imitate sounds,
create art,
give bad news to an enemy,
fantasize about pleasant situations.
And Skinner says that they all involve reinforcement.
Those are all reinforced behaviors.
But Skinner doesn't literally mean that when we talk to ourselves,
somebody gives us food pellets.
He doesn't literally mean even that when we talk to ourselves,
somebody passes on a headset.
Good man.
Perfect.
I'm very proud
what he means.
For instance,
this case is well talk into yourself as self reinforcing or I'm giving bad news
to an enemy is reinforcing because it makes your enemy feel bad.
Well,
Chomsky says the problem is it's not that that's wrong,
that's all true.
It's just so vague as to be useless.
Skinner isn't saying anything more to say.
Giving bad news to an enemy is reinforcing because it makes the enemy feel bad.
Doesn't say anything different from giving bad news to an enemy feels good
because we like to give bad news to an enemy.
It just putting in more scientific terms more generally,
Chompsky suggests that the law of effect when applied to humans is either
trivially true trivially or uninterruptedly true or scientifically robust and
obviously false.
So if you want to expand the notion of reward or reinforcement to anything,
then it's true.
So why did you,
um,
why did you come?
Those of you who are not freshmen,
oh,
why did you come?
All of you.
Why did you come to Yale for a second semester?
Well,
I repeated my action because the first semester was rewarding.
Okay.
What do you mean by that?
Well,
you don't literally mean that somebody rewarded you,
like gave you pellets and stuff.
Um,
well you mean as you chose to come here for the second semester and there's
nothing wrong with saying that,
but we shouldn't confuse it with science.
And more generally,
the problem is you can talk about what other people do in terms of reinforcement
and punishment and operative conditioning,
classical conditioning.
But in order to do so,
you have to use terms like punishment and reward and reinforcement in such a
vague way that in the end you're not saying anything scientific.
So behaviorism as a dominant intellectual field has faded,
but it still leaves behind an important legacy and instilled,
it still stands as one of the major contributions of 20th century psychology.
Um,
for one thing,
it has given us a richer understanding of certain learning mechanisms,
particularly with regard to nonhumans mechanisms like habituation,
classical conditioning and operant conditioning are real.
They can be scientifically studied and they play an important role in the lives
of animals and probably an important role in human lives as well.
They just don't explain everything.
Finally,
and this is something we're going to return to on Wednesday,
actually.
Um,
behaviors have provided powerful techniques for training,
particularly for nonverbal creatures.
So this extends to animal trainers,
but it also extends to people who want to teach young children and babies and
also want to help populations like the severely autistic are the severely
retarded.
Many of these behaviors,
techniques have proven to be quite useful.
And in that regard,
as well as in other regards,
it stands as an important contribution.